that's why i'm running for senate i'm dr
oz and i approve this message dr oz
announces he's running for office we're
a can-do people the surgeon and tv
personality is launching a bid for the
u.s senate in pennsylvania pennsylvania
needs a conservative who will put
america first dr oz full name mamet az
is running as a republican in the
primary race he announced his candidacy
tuesday in this one-minute video citing
his frustration with washington's
response to the pandemic as his
motivation covid has shown us that our
system is broken we lost too many lives
too many jobs and too many opportunities
because washington got it wrong in an
op-ed for the washington examiner oz
expanded on that message writing quote
we have not managed our crisis as
effectively as past generations during
the pandemic i learned that when you mix
politics and medicine you get politics
instead of solutions that's the big
message e.t spoke with a daytime tv
doctor back in early march 2020 as the
pandemic gripped the country we mobilize
when we have emergencies and disasters
and this is a good time to do just that
we can deal with it we can get past it
support each other through the
affections we may have make sure we
don't get grandma with chronic illnesses
infected and in that way weather the
storm dr oz first came into the
spotlight as a guest on the oprah
winfrey show in 2004. his own daytime
talk show the dr oz show premiered in
2009. i spent a lot of time thinking
about what's going on right now in
america last year the series was renewed
for two more seasons keeping it on the
air through 2023 we're very optimistic
e.t was with the famous dock after his
daytime emmy win back in 2018 and he
opened up about the integrity behind the
show you know i put these emmys in the
studio entryway because i want the staff
hundred people walking in every day to
look at these emmys and realize my
goodness we worked really hard to get
these we don't want to ever sell our
audience short because the brand of the
show is trust right and trust is not
just doing the right thing it's being
competent
to do the right thing yeah